معنا من حيفا ايهاب جبارين الكاتب المختص
في الشان
الاسرائيلي ضيفنا مرحبا بك يعني الضغط و
هذا النقاش الاعلامي والضغط
الشعبي لم يقتصر فقط كما نتابع عبر
الشاشات انضم ايزنكوت
وحتى جانس الى تغيير الاولويات والتركيز
على اطلاق سراح الاسرى والمحتجزين
بالتسميه الاسرائيليه اولا قبل كل شيء مد
تغير في النظره الاسرائيليه لهذا
الملف نعم تحياتي استاذ محمد و مساء الخير
يعني ربما قبل ذلك تجدر الاشاره لنقطه
مهمه جدا من يشاهد هذا الشريط الذي بثته
بثبته قبل قليل يمكن القول ان المدير
الاعلامي لحماس انا باعتقادي يعني سكن او
عاش في تلبيب لمدى 20 عام سبقت هذا ما
يمكن ان يقوله يعني الاعلام المكتب
الاعلامي لحماس باعتقادي يتقن ويجيد
اللعبه بالاعصاب في داخل الشارع
الاسرائيلي الحرب النفسيه بادق التفاصيل
ما يك بثه اليوم هو بنمط الريالي الشارع
الاسرائيلي الجمهور الاسرائيلي يتلقن او
على الاقل في العشر سنوات الاخيره عاش في
ضمن منظومه الريالي بكل معنى الكلمه برامج
الطبيخ برامج الموسيقى كلها كان يعيش في
منظومه رياليتي والان يبث اليه في هذا في
هذه ادق التفاصيل انا باعتقادي هذه نقطه
يعني تحتسب ولديها اثرها الكبير على وعي
الشارع الاسرائيلي هذا الامر الاول كذلك
الخطاب يوم امس وهي نقطه مهمه جدا تجدر
الاشاره اليها ملخص الخطاب ابو عبيده يوم
امس هو بكلمتين يمكن القول يعني ل ك لو
تمت ترجمته لللغه العضيه سوف يكون حماس
يتسني حماس جدي وهذا كذلك ما استنبطه
الشارع الاسرائيلي في مدى الاسابيع
الاخيره هذا التغيير انا باعتقادي في مدى
الصمود في في الطرف الاخر لدى حماس هذا
اللعبه هي كانت كانت من البدايه حرب اعصاب
كما كنا قد ذكرنا من الجانب الاسرائيلي
عرض عسكري كبير يتم اخضاع ويتم بعثره
الاوراق في داخل القطاع ولكن على ما يبدو
ان اللعبه كانت مرتده على داخل تل ابيب
بعثرت الاوراق موجوده في داخل تل ابيب
عندما يخرج ايزنكوت ويقولها بصريح العباره
ان هو يعني يجب ان يكون هنالك نوع من
الشجاعه يجب ان تتسم القياده الاسرائيليه
بنوع من الشجاعه اي بكلمات اخرى ان ما
تخوضه الان في قضم هذه الفتره هو فقط
مهاترات ومهاترات
اعلاميه وضجيج اعلامي ليس الا هذا في
المقام الاول وكذلك هنالك شخص الذي كان
يعني لديه ضلع في المفاوضات
بابان جلعاد شليت وصفقه جلعاد شليت والذي
يقولها بصريح العباره انه هذه الصفقه كانت
يجب ان تتم في الاسابيع الاولى الكل مقابل
الكل كانت يجب ان تتم في الاسابيع الاولى
الان ليس فقط مجرد الكل مقابل الكل بل
الكل مقابل الكل والانسحاب وانهاء الحار
يعني هذا الامر كنا يجب ان كان ممكن ان
نتخطاها اصلا في الاسابيع الاولى وهو يقول
من تجربتي في المفاوضات ومما اسمعه من من
الجانب المصري و وما يوصل الي من الجانب
القطري انا ممكن ان افهم ان حماس جدي الى
ابعد الحدود في كل هذه الجزئيه وبالتالي
لهذا السبب انا باعتقادي التغيير الذي
نراه في الجانب الاسرائيلي على مدى ال
يعني الاسابيع الاخيره الجرف هذا وهنالك
كذلك نقطه مهمه جدا عندما يخرج
170 رجال امن ومخابرات اسرائيليون ويقومون
بتوقيع على مثل هذه الوثيقه التي تطالب
باستبدال الحكومه في ظرف الوضع الجاي هذا
دلاله على شهاده فشل لهذه الحكومه
وبالتالي يعني نتنياهو اصلا لم يكن يابه
لمهات لابيد او اي من السياسيون لانه لا
يعمل لهم حساب ولا يعرف جيدا ان في نهايه
المطاف كفاءه السياسيون في داخل اسرائيل
عمل عليها هو على مدى سنوات كثيره بان
تكون ما دون المستوى لكن عندما يخرج قياض
في الامن و وساس امنيون ويقولون مثل هذا
الكلام هو يعرف انه بدا
ي واليمين يعني هذه التحركات في اوساط
الجيش وحتى التوقيعات التي اشرت اليها هي
نتيجه سير المعركه ليس فقط الاسرى انت كيف
تقيم ما هو حجم التاثير الفعلي لما يجري
مع الاسرى داخل غزه وسير المعارك في
التاثير على استقرار
الحكومه يعني حتى في سير المعركه في داخل
سير في خضام سير المعركه هنالك من يقول
نحن بتنا في المرحله الثالثه نحن لسنا لا
نتوجه ال المرحله الثالثه نحن بتنا في
داخل المرحله الثالثه وع قليل يجب ان ندخل
في المرحله الرابعه والمرحله الرابعه هي
يعني وفق المعايير العسكريه او وفق ما
يفهمه يعني الرتب العسكريه يجب ان تكون
استبدال الحكم ونحن لا يوجد لدينا اي
دلالات اصلا اننا قريبين من استبدال للحكم
فبالتالي نحن لسنا موجودين فقط في في
المرحله الثالثه نحن حتما سوف نعود الى
المرحله الثانيه من كيفيه اداره هذه
المعركه هكذا يعني يسمونها برفق معاييرهم
فبالتالي واضح جدا ان اصلا في البدايه عدم
وجود هنالك عندما يخرج الكابينيت او حتى
اذا هي كانت في جلسه غير رسميه للكابينه
عندما يخرج ويكون هنالك هذا الفق وهذا
الشرخ على سلم الاولويات اعاده الاسرى او
الاطاحه بحماس اولا عندما يكون هذا الشرخ
في في في في هذه الجز
هذا يعكس كل حجم البلبله في اداره المعركه
في نهايه المطاف وهي نقطه مهمه جدا يجب ان
نتذكرها ان في نهايه المطاف كل ما نشاهده
الان هو خضم ما قام بنيامين نتنياهو بشخصه
ب التحضير له على مدى خمس سنوات وكان
يتغذى من كل هذه البلبله في القياضه والان
هو يتغذى منها بشكل شخصي وبشكل مباشر قسام
تقول سنفصله عن مصير ثلاثه من الاسر يعني
الليله فيديو عنهم الان في هذا الوقت
الظهيره فيديو عن مصيرهم غموض اخر حتى
المساء لماذا التركيز في هذه الفتره
الزمنيه في يوم واحد ولا بد ان نشير الى
الشارع المتواجد حاليا
والضاغط هذا ما كنت قد اشرت
اليه المدير المكتب الاعلام العسكري انا
باعتقادي سكن او دارس الشارع الاسرائيلي
بكل
حذافيره ان صح القول يعني هو يعلم جيدا
مدى تاثير هذه الاشرطه وانا باعتقادي ان
لهذه الاشرطه وان كانت اسرائيل قد فرضت
حصار اعلامي على مدى الثلاثه اشهر السابقه
على اعلامها بلا
يبث هذه الاشرطه وال يستهلكها وما الى ذلك
ولكن في نهايه المطاف في الشارع في السطر
الاخير الشارع الاسرائيلي يستقبل هذه
الفيديوهات من السوشال ميديا او حتى من
متابعه الجزيره بن بنفسها فبالتالي واضح
جدا ان في نهايه المطاف هنالك اثر كبير
للتحركات في داخل الميدان بل هنالك يعني
بنيامين نتنياهو و وقام ببث ذلك او مثل
هذه التسريبات الى داخل الشارع الاسرائيلي
بقوله ان وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا الاحتجاج
الذي تقومون به انتم ذوي الاسر في داخل
الشارع الاسرائيلي هو ما يغذي اصلا الطرف
الاخر هو ما يغذي حماس في تقويه مساله
المفاوضات واعاقه اعاده الاسرى الى هذا
المدى هو يبعد وياخذها بنيامين نتنياهو
بان يحاول ان يضرب كل ما يجري في داخل
الشارع الاسرائيلي يعني هو يحاول ان يقوم
بضربه مرتده ولكن هذه النقطه مهمه جدا انا
باعتقادي ان اسرائيل كل تحركاتها الحكومه
الكابينت كل تحركاته هو مجرد ردود فعل حتى
هذه المرحله هو لم يقدم على خطوه سابقه
على الاقل على المستوى الاعلامي من حيث
ايهاب جبرين الكاتب المختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك